first we begin with joe biden last night
yes your fearless leader
came out of hiding for a very special
town hall
very few people watched on fake news cnn
and despite a never-ending stream of
softball questions and
plenty of coddling from don lemon well
the town hall was
an well charitably i'll say an
unmitigated disaster
now many of joe's answers were
completely incomprehensible
at times no one seemed to know what the
hell joe was even talking about
not even don lemon not the audience not
even joe himself
but as usual we let you decide
i've heard you speak about it because
you always i'm not being solicitous but
you
you're always straight up about what
you're doing and the question is whether
or not
we should be in a position where you uh
um
are why can't the the
the experts say we know
that this virus is in fact
uh um uh is it it's going to be
our assuming we we know why all the
drugs approved are not temporarily
approved
but permanently approved that's underway
too i expect that to occur quickly well
that
means you mean for the fda for the fda
there are trusted
interlocutors think of the people if if
your kid
wanted to find out whether or not there
were
there's a man on the moon or whatever
you know something
or you know whether those aliens are
here or not
you know who are the people they talk to
beyond the kids who love talking about
it
they go to people they respect okay we
have a president who
to be charitable again at times is
completely
unable to communicate a total cognitive
mess
and i know i've joked about it in the
past but it's really not funny anymore
this is a real national security crisis
that has emerged not only for the u.s
but the world
and it's completely being ignored by the
media mob
the big tech mob the twitter blue check
uh mob and big tech cult that exists
they only seem to talk to each other
but when joe was able to form a
semi-coherent sentence well
he was almost always lying now the first
example involves crime in america
according to your president joe biden
crime is actually down he says
watch for yourself now i'm not being a
wise guy there's no reason you should
have you seen my gun violence
legislation i've introduced
as you know because you're so involved
actually crime is down gun violence and
murder rates are up
guns okay joe you're the president but
i'll help you out
murder is way up in every major city in
the country assaults are up carjackings
they've spiked also oh out there in
california the socialist paradise that
it is
shoplifting now is so bad because
they're not going to arrest you or
charge you unless you steal over a
thousand dollars
retailers now have to close early and
some retailers have closed
locations permanently because of the
never-ending
theft just look at your screen right now
look at what's happening here
it's happening all over california
crooks what they do is they come in with
like garbage bags they
fill them up with merchandise keep it
under a thousand bucks so they don't get
in trouble
and they just walk right out of the
store and in joe's reality everything's
free
wow what about how did how does a
business ever get to stay in business
that way
they rarely get arrested and almost
never get prosecuted but according to
joe biden
the real problem in this country that's
americans
who lawfully exercise your second
amendment rights
your constitutional rights watch this
the idea you need a weapon that can
have the ability to fire 20 30
40 50 120 shots from that weapon whether
it's a well
whether it's a nine millimeter pistol or
whether it's a rifle
is ridiculous i'm continuing to push to
eliminate the sale of those things
okay joe i own nine millimeter weapons
um
i even have a license to carry a nine
millimeter weapon
it's a handgun it's one of the most
basic self-defense weapons
and there is no 120 clip magazine for a
nine
millimeter pistol that i've ever heard
of but i'm open to seeing it if you
could show it to me
but i wouldn't expect joe biden to know
that because he barely seems to know
what day of the week it is
and doesn't really seem to have a firm
grasp on any
issues of any substance and sometimes
well it seems like he's living in this
you know alternate alternate reality of
his in fact
i get this according to joe there's no
longer a crisis
at our southern border this is what they
call
well a burger king a whopper with cheese
and double bread and double you know
meat take a look we have been able to
move significantly
to change the number there were
thousands of people
in in uh in custody with the border
patrol
it's now cut by 90 percent where there
is considerably downscript
all right joe there are fewer migrants
uh
in dhs custody because your
administration i'll tell you why
you are releasing them all over the
country
and of course migrants continue to pour
across the southern border
in droves here we got the numbers for
june yep
another record 188 000 migrants
entering our country illegally and
that's only the numbers that we know
about
now this is in the new york times joe
and i assume you're still able to read
but i digress the next lie from joe
biden that would involve
inflation which every american is
feeling
and it's really bad watch
guess what instead of paying 10 cents
you're paying 20.
i mean you understand what i'm saying it
relates to
what in fact is now needed because we're
growing
i don't know anybody including larry
summers who's a friend of mine
who's worried about inflation is
suggesting that there's any long-term
march here if we do the things we're
going to do
so the economist that joe is referring
to has a name his name is
lawrence summers and he literally wrote
an op-ed entitled
the inflation risk is real articles in
the wall street journal
articles in forbes and bloomberg also
discuss
the long-term inflation risk uh it's
getting bad
we even now are calculating the misery
index that we really haven't measured
since jimmy carter
and even biden's own treasury secretary
janet yellen warned of
months of rapid inflation um
maybe joe missed that meeting or maybe
he just forgot or maybe just sent kamala
harris
to do more of the jobs that he's
supposed to do
now inflation is not only you know a
glaring concern in the biden economy
another serious
problem surrounds the massive labor
shortage that's real too
in many cases businesses now are
completely unable to fill
job openings because of biden's generous
coven 19 handouts that continue to go on
but don't worry according to joe if
you're a business owner
you can just magically print money and
pay
everyone more and you're probably going
to have to suffer more
kind of sounded like jimmy carter saying
lower your heat and put a sweater on
take a look my guess is that um
people being seven eight dollars an hour
plus tips
that that's i think john you're going to
be finding
15 bucks an hour or more now you said
we're going to
end the things that may be keeping
people back
do you think that's the unemployment
benefits well that was hard it was i i i
don't think it did much but the point is
it's argued that
because the extended unemployment
benefits kept people they'd rather
stay home and not work than go to work
you don't think it
did that i i see no evidence that had
any serious impact on him
and yes there you have yet another live
from joe biden according to multiple
reports the biden unemployment benefits
are keeping workers home and get this
the jobless rate
sadly it just went up again but
according to biden
well who has by the way never actually
worked in a business he's been
in the swamp the sewer for what 50 plus
years
maybe 500 depending how you do math
outside of hunter's pay for play schemes
he did make money there
to be fair we got to report all his
income
we now know that he directly benefited
from zero experience hunter
now these greedy business owners just
have to pay people more money
okay how much are other people willing
to pay for a hamburger cheeseburger
french fries
you know between the lying the insults
the stammering
the you know confusion of joe biden well
that town hall was to say the least
tough to watch for the few people that
actually watched it
one washington post reporter noted quote
president biden
has said not a joke at least
seven times the past 30 minutes in other
words
it's not a joke literally sad but it's
true
this is your president you decide again
it really has not a joke i'm not joking
not a joke not a joke not a joke
not a joke i mean i'm not joking
not a joke come on man did you use
cocaine
are you a junkie well that was a moment
during the campaign one of the rare
moments he left his basement bunker
i guess the only saving grace for the
biden administration
is that very few people saw it more
people watched
our town hall from miami and look at
this
the auditorium for joe was half empty
wow doesn't look like a trump rally in
any way does it
and while many on the left would like to
ignore joe biden altogether
well it's way past time that the
administration answers
serious questions about the president's
clear cognitive decline
it is no longer in dispute but don't
expect tough questions from the media
mob they will keep him
in the media mob big tech protection
program
at all costs and needless to say this
probably
you know will be the last town hall
we'll see in a very long time hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else